une cinquantaine d'années écrit
jean-claude juste après l'agrandissement
du musée johnny hallyday qui aura été
inaugurée par le fils de jade mes petits
enfants apprendront que tu es décédé que
tu as reçu des funérailles nationales
comme je ne serai plus là pour en parler
avec toi dit-il jean-claude merci de me
dire ce que tu penses de cette idée de
funérailles nationales
allez on jette à l'eau johnny gens
peuvent pas grand chose je pense que je
sais c'est pas terrible
vous êtes une star absolue ce serait
dommage absolue je ne suis pas une star
les gens s'imaginent ça moi je suis un
homme sap vous savez je veux avec le
batteur moi j'ai une petite jade
aujourd'hui une pléiade qui ma fille que
j'aime
vous savez quand je me réveille qu'elle
me regarde en face et qu'elle veut
sauver que qu'elle dit papa elle a dit
jiwa chez les filles belles choses
auront leur âge banques
[Musique]